alright hey everybody
see if we get this party started
maybe question is am i coming through
heck with it
hey cool this is Major Tom to ground
control hey everybody um this one is
actually I'm going to set a hard stop at
an hour because I have two videos I need
to shoot before I go to bed after this
is done I had meant to shoot one of them
last night but I was too dang tired so
now I have to shoot two tonight so fun
stuff it actually is fine to enjoy doing
it but you know my body wants me to
sleep
stupid stupid body do you eat beans not
by themselves that much I mean green
beans maybe but like in stuff yeah
Liz actually makes pretty good taco and
nacho stuff she often uses black beans
with that I like refried but yeah
usually as a complement to something
that's an odd question to start the
night off with uh no theme tonight I'm
just yeah I'm just kind of William baked
beans I you know baked beans sometimes
um but again usually a favor I've got
something you can put them on like if
there's like I'll do baked beans on a
hot dog basically have Franks and beans
oh I come down for that every now and
then nice shirt nice I do love I do like
this shirt it's funny because of the the
way that I currently have the the camera
set up and framed for the videos you
actually can't tell what's on my shirt
like nine times out of ten because it
cuts off at like maybe right about here
aha so unless I decide to change the the
camera angle again the shirts I wear
don't even matter these days so it's
kind of nice that they get they get
noticed here peanut butter or Nutella
neither cookie butter missed you I
missed you too
yeah I'm sorry I like I was bad about
reminding everybody last week that I was
on vacation there wasn't gonna be a live
stream I mentioned it at the end of the
previous live stream but like I meant to
send out a reminder and that's that's on
me that was a fail on my part mr. Bean's
Holiday Review I like mr. bean that much
mmm if I'm gonna watch Rowan Atkinson I
would much rather watch Black Adder
I had pumpkin spice cookie butter last
fall ooh now that's that's that's one
too many things I think mr. Bean's
Holiday is a masterpiece and cool enjoy
you can have it first life's dream I
managed to catch it over two months any
new drinking questions no not not this
time um so like you know same ones they
actually don't get asked as often I
these because the the live stream is
largely a group of regulars at this
point I don't think we give you too many
drop ins who like having never been
involved in the live stream previously I
don't think that happens all that much
at this point
welcome back did you have a reverse the
polarity drink on you Herve Kate I know
they they they weren't that inventive
with the drinks where I was though I did
have um some rather tasty variants on on
margaritas and a blue Hawaiian so that
was nice have you watched the thin blue
line aren't there like four or five
different things that use that title I
can remember there was an indie movie
like Ben
90s and there was a show I think there's
like a book is but like none of them are
related they all just used that same
title so like you asked me that I don't
know I don't I don't even know what it's
referring to
so I once upon a time in Hollywood last
week I liked it but I felt like it was
all over the place in a bit
self-indulgent I haven't seen that one
I I haven't seen a Tarantino movie in
theaters since Kill Bill Vol - um I
usually get around to seeing all of his
movies eventually but mmm he's he's one
of those guys who I know I'll eventually
want to see everything he's done but
I've never felt the need to rewatch
anything he's made even the stuff of his
that I really like I still haven't felt
really a need to go back and we watch it
so I kind of a weird relationship with
him
do you watch Lucifer from Netflix no
because I gave up on Lucifer after three
episodes of season one I was like I'm
not having fun with this other people do
which is great I'm not gonna say it's a
bad show but it didn't appeal to me The
Iron Giant was released in theaters 20
years ago today oh boy
make me feel old I was working in a
movie theater when that came out oh boy
did you see the thick blue line I Eretz
by BIC ah nicely done
I don't know if you guys are gonna be
able to hear it I betcha this thing
doesn't pick it up but there's thunder
going on where I am it's raining outside
probably not bad enough to be picked up
by the mic but III just had a nice
little a nice little rumble a thunder
you were sixteen or seventeen not that
bad I would have been yeah I would have
been seventeen in 99
I'm staring down the barrel at 40 I
can't even claim mid-thirties anymore I
don't think he can reasonably claim
mid-30s once he had 37 unless you're
gonna get like super pedantic about and
be like I'm I'm late mid third like now
you're just splitting hairs I'm in my
late 30s
ah I was 21 in 99 okay so I mean I'm not
the oldest guy in the room that's
something I thought you were 29 you why
but thank you I'm flattered I thought
that said I did actually get carded last
week while on vacation twice that hasn't
happened in a while although honestly it
happened on the same day I think it was
because this was a family vacation so I
went with my daughter and with her
mother we still all do family vacation
together even though we're not we're not
married anymore and we still do it every
year and she she actually did my hair in
a French braid during a chunk of time
when when our daughter was off doing her
own thing because she's old enough to do
some stuff on her own at this point uh
and I suddenly about the French braid
must have made me look young or at least
like I was trying to look young because
that once she did that I got carded
twice so that was a little odd I wasn't
born in 99 and there it is
there's making me feel nice and old I
was in negative numbers in 99 oh boy I
was 36 and 99 okay well I bow to your
superior experience you don't look a day
over 32 thank you I don't believe you
but thank you but then again like you
know I think like most of us I'm
self-critical I look in the mirror and
go oh boy yeah but yeah what can you do
we all rolled but
BC alternative I was conceived in 99 no
more information required thank you very
much
32 that is oddly specific any old or
obscure series recommendations um oh no
like I I never really had much success
getting into like TV from before my time
I can't really think there was really
much of anything I sunk much time into
along those lines like I haven't even
seen that much original series Star Trek
like it's just kind of hard for me to
digest have you ever heard the song you
can call me out by Paul Simon of course
I have I I maybe I missed a segue into
that question earlier in the chat so I
don't know why I came up but yeah that's
a great song it's weird like if you
actually stop and look at the lyrics and
try and suss out what is even going on
but it's a good song I'm marathoning the
MCU movies in chronological order
Incredible Hulk is my next movie oh well
you know just power through that and
Iron Man - you'll be fine it's it's it's
better after that
it's cheeky of me thoughts on planet of
the Daleks I haven't seen that one yet
there's still a lot of classic that I
have not excuse me that I have not seen
I do intend to try and start picking up
the pace of that partly because um and I
don't even ounce this to anyone outside
the patreon yeah but I'll mention it
here but the plan for the the podcast
feed is a lot not all but a lot of the
classic Doctor Who reviews are gonna
move over there that's not to say that
will never do classic Doctor Who reviews
on the channel again it's just that like
they don't right now I'm getting through
them out of pace of like one a month
maybe
never what every two months kind of
these days and I I want to get through
it a lot faster but also the classic who
reviews aren't some of my better viewed
stuff and anyway any youtuber who does
this regularly as more than just a hobby
who tells you that the the views don't
matter is lying they do because if like
I have I have my own sort of bare metric
for like okay that's that's okay to keep
talking about that kind of topic and if
I fail to meet it repeatedly it's like
maybe I should stop doing that and
classic who reviews if it isn't a
well-known story or a well-regarded
story then they don't do well but I'll
still do some of the big stuff on the
channel like when I get to Genesis of
the Daleks and the five doctors and
maybe I'll do the key to time as a video
stuff like that but like there's a ton
of stories that just I just need to see
so that they're seen
so what I'll end up doing is I'll do
reviews for those four ones I don't do
video reviews for on the podcast feed
and I don't have a date on when that's
gonna start up I don't wanna I don't
want to commit to it because right now I
am trying to regain my cushion so I was
usually like about two weeks ahead in
terms of video production but taking a
vacation ate through a good chunk of
that and I'm trying to get my lead in
again so that before I before I commit
too much to a schedule for for
podcasting stuff you can call me Dalek
by Paul Dalek ah and it starts according
to Paul Simon the song was basically
alluding to an identity crisis he was
going through during his time in Africa
I mean it's an 80s song so yeah lots of
pop stars were spending time in Africa
with uh office some very weird results
thoughts on chasing amy Oh see the thing
is I
we need to go back and watch it again
because it's been so long since I've
seen it and so many of my opinions about
the kind of media that cheesy Amy is
have evolved so much from the last time
that I've seen it I really feel like I
need to give it a full watch again but
to my memory of it assuming that that is
accurate who knows but to my memory of
it it is an approach to that kind of
story that is interesting and it's got a
it's got a good angle and a good
approach to it it's got a couple of
stumbling points along this way in terms
of execution but it's coming from a good
place in terms of trying to tell that
kind of story about those kinds of
characters and specifically a non
straight female character respectfully
and how well it does it that's like the
part of my memory that I feel like is
hazy at this point I need to refresh but
my general thought on it is I remember
I'd certainly liked it at the time the
question for me now is is how does it
hold up now that I kind of I'm more woke
for lack of a less cringy way to put it
I'm also gonna be auditioning for the
complete works of Shakespeare or bridge
this Saturday oh good luck that's an
awesome show complete works of
Shakespeare abridged is phenomenal
that's such a fun show so good luck
seriously starting the Chibcha the tip
sheet starting the tip jar train
everyone can jump on Thank You Bridget
somebody's got a pop that cherry and I
just made a weird go me uh anything to
declare about Indiana Jones ranking of
the first three did you like Crystal
Skull are you excited for a fifth one
I'm not excited for a fifth one because
like I I don't want to see Indy that old
I just don't um I actually don't dislike
crystal skull as much as most most
but I actually I I haven't I haven't
rewatched either of these in a while but
I think I kind of prefer crystal skull
to Temple of Doom I really don't like
Temple of Doom I get all um to me like
the the first one's the best one rate is
a Lost Ark is the best one Bar None and
then it's Last Crusade and then like
maybe Crystal Skull and then Temple of
Doom but like for other peoples probably
flipped temple of doom is not good it's
not it's got a couple of decent moments
but it's not good um did I ever tell you
that I once did a livestream with
phantom Strider hopefully you're
familiar with his work embarassingly
no I am not punishment shot it is
actually just water this time like I
said I have two videos I have to shoot
after this I'm not playing to get
sloshed so far as anyone knows that's my
story I'm sticking to it
and why not ah Thank You Jesse I'm I
appreciate it I really do
he specializes in animation ooh okay
well that might be something worth
checking out then I do I mean like I I
love I obviously love animation and um
sort of finding some of the some of the
cool channels that talk a lot about
animation has been fun for me like I
found sell specs earlier in the year and
I like I like her stuff a lot
well Thank You Tracy do you know what
else was weird
the penchant for TV shows with music
videos I'm looking at you kid video and
new monkeys also NKOTB the cartoon well
let us not forget hammer man the MC
Hammer cartoon hey she saw an episode of
that once it's like a very faded memory
but I was hoping you would Rock the
sunglasses for the whole thing no no
like that like the the sunglasses those
are those are
like if he just would've been seeking
the phone I'm doing this on the whole
time
Last Crusade is my favorite of the
Indiana Jones movies the leap of faith
is one of the best moments I've seen in
movies also I saw it for the first time
in theaters some years ago very cool
I saw it in the theaters wet the year it
came out 89 was a was a busy year for
theaters cuz we had that we had Batman
was 89 Ghostbusters 2 was 89 at some
point I don't know when because what I
want to do for it is somewhat elaborate
but I am going to dedicate a video on
Ghostbusters 2 that is going to happen
when I don't know but die Axley have to
cleanse that idea out of my head license
to kill was 89 no never saw that one
pop-culture detective is good to ya know
that they're good stuff uh anyone see
Kyoto Japan's movie a silent voice now I
haven't seen I know about the fire at
the Kyoto Animation um I don't think
I've seen any of their stuff which I
felt really bad I'd like a I would have
loved to have been able to sincerely
offer you know a shout out or a
recommendation of their stuff but I
couldn't cuz I hadn't seen any of it so
in anything I said would have been
incredibly insincere but that was a from
a few weeks back that was a very very
sad story when you have enough alcohol I
mean water uh I saw a Ghostbusters 2 on
a class trip whatever you were going to
I hope it was worth it thoughts on
Studio Ghibli I like their stuff I mean
I've seen almost all of Miyazaki's films
I think the only one I haven't seen at
this point is a castle of Cagliostro
I've seen all the rest and I but I've
only seen a couple of the Ghibli films
directed by other people I do need to
see more of those I have seen grave of
fireflies but like there's a bunch I've
seen I haven't seen the cap returns
I haven't seen marty was here yeah a
whole bunch of these that I seldom seen
ghostbusters legit scared the crap out
of me as a kid um I remember I see I
remember seeing the original
Ghostbusters in the theater but it must
have been on a on a rerelease because
showing my age back in the days before
video rental was ubiquitous and owning
home media was really expensive um it
was not and not nearly as many movies
got released to theaters it was not
uncommon for successful movies from a
few years prior to get re released in
theaters again if it was a slow period
so I think I was probably four or five
um when I saw Ghostbusters in the
theater on some kind of a really
rerelease cuz the movie came out when I
was two there's no way my mother took me
to see when I was two the whip the
wizard was 89 I've never seen that one
but I know it by reputation there's an
interesting film on Amazon called the
history of time-travel is that a
fictional work or is that like history
of it in like in writing and in
entertainment cuz if no one's made that
documentary I want to see that have you
ever seen a Keira mmm I have I I don't
love it I think it's actually fairly
overrated it's visually astounding but I
say this every now and then when I have
to I'm a story person first and the
story doesn't do a lot for me on that
one
Thank You Bridget I've been watching
Avatar The Last Airbender your thoughts
ah I haven't seen it like any of it not
even like like a single complete episode
which you know is a point of shame
what comedic YouTube channels do you
watch um
I don't watch everything they put out
but I am subscribed to college humor and
there's ones that I that I watch that do
humorous stuff but maybe it's not
necessarily humor channel like I'm
subscribed to dorkly and some of their
stuff is quite funny I'm still
subscribed to screen junkies and but I
don't always feel the need to jump on
the honest trailers as much as I used to
but I'm still subscribed to that I don't
think there's a ton that like is
designed as comedy that I'm like oh yeah
I gotta be sure I see everything they
put out because most comedic channels
you know they have a formula and that'll
work for me for a while but then I'll be
like I feel like I figured out your
formula and then I kind of move on I
haven't watched avatar either oh good
I'm not alone uh Doctor Who in which is
familiar what did Missy do with the
talax
and when they try I can't quite make out
your question the the texts came through
a little garbled something about
regeneration energy I'm not I haven't
rewatched which is familiar in a while
so I may not even be properly
remembering what you're referring to
I've got a soft spot for Kiki's Delivery
Service people who know me know why haha
I have a suspicion as to why Carolyn for
me like probably nostalgically my
favorite um Miyazaki is probably
Princess Mononoke was the first one I
saw I honestly think my neighbor totoro
is his best one though personally I I
think it's the the perfect distillation
of everything he's
really good at um I think that one might
be my daughter's favorite - I think this
one yes for the most she's seen a fair
chunk of them um she's she's seen that
she's seen swept away she's seen Kiki's
Delivery Service she's seen Howl's
Moving Castle
she liked Calcifer a lot but I think
Paltrow's I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say that's the one she likes best cuz
it's the one she's asked for most I
haven't shown her Mononoke yet when
she's old enough for it because Mononoke
it gets intense at times when she's old
enough I think she's gonna love it
but like I gotta I gotta figure out when
the heck that is I just started watching
Xuan on your recommendation I'm loving
it yes another converted excellent so
many of my favorite films as a kid came
out in 89 Honey I Shrunk the Kids Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure and uhf yeah
89 was a solid year all things
considered as far as movies go I don't
know what else was going on in the world
I was seven I didn't read the news I
look a spear in a way and like the
characters know Mike's like our returns
i I need to see all that I'm gonna jump
back to the discord real quick cuz I
don't know if too much was sort of
tossed out over there for me to take a
look at but let me just check real quick
oh um what kind of water will you be
drinking tonight let's see have you
watched the boys on Amazon Prime or
another life on Netflix if you haven't
what you want - I'm actually not even
sure what another life is the boys I I
haven't seen and I think I've mentioned
this before or it's largely because it's
based off a car comic book by Garth
Ennis and I don't I don't hate Gareth
honest but he
sonmi quickly the phrase I'm I'm partial
to explaining why I don't particularly
like Garth Ennis is the man's about 70%
as clever as he thinks he is which you
know just rubs me the wrong way after a
while I love Shira the original king
came out when I was seven and up my time
you watch this is a bigger bag it's a
little too fighty
and she's not huge into action um shows
or movies but oh no pickup buffering so
Garth Ennis is Steven Moffat basically
well um I would say Steven Moffat has
the best slightly better track record
think well no here's what I'll say um
Garth Ennis is consistently 70 percent
of clever as he thinks he is Moffat
wavers sometimes Moffat is in fact as
clever as he thinks he is
other times he is batting more like 50%
as clever as he thinks he is so I would
say he probably averages about the same
but doing this as opposed to Ennis was
at one level I don't know why I did
lightsaber sound effects mmm-hmm
I had a lot of trouble with buffering
all good now oh good slightly out of
sync well maybe I'm just really good at
throwing my voice everything of that I
I'm actually a puppet there's a
ventriloquist just off-screen
would you rewrite let's kill Hitler if
so how I don't know it's been too long
since I've seen it and the thing is I
don't have issues with that episode at
least to my memory a lot of people seem
to UM seem to crap on that one and I've
never quite understood why thoughts on
the original Blade Runner original Blade
Runner is one of my favorite movies of
all time and that was before I even saw
like the good cut that was like that was
like the crappy cut that that uh that I
grew up that I grew up on like going
with a voiceover what heard Harrison
Ford deliberately sounded half-asleep
and uninterested hoping to god it would
mean the voice-over was so bad they
didn't use it like that's the version I
fell in love with as a kid so I
obviously have now seen a much better
versions of the movie the final cut is
is the one to see the one they got the
blu-ray release but ya know I loved
Blade Runner marionette puppet or hand
up butt puppet no comment
man or woman adult or child life or
death
are we just bellowing out options is
that what we're doing Peter Capaldi's
doctor was a miserable get depends on
the series he wasn't series 8 a bit a
little bit but he got better have you
ever seen the renegade cut of Highlander
due to I haven't and I've heard it like
quote-unquote makes it better I can't
imagine how like the whole notion is
just insane are you a man or a woman I
am curious I don't know how to answer
that cuz I don't know if you're asking
me about my actual physical biology
which isn't really anybody's business or
if you're asking about my identity which
is gender fluid so that's kind of both
but also neither so don't really know
how to answer the question the way that
your phrasing it I'm trying trying to
work with you here are there any stories
or moments in Doctor Who that try to be
serious but you just can't take steer
very nicely um I mean yeah probably I'm
having a hard time pulling any off the
top my head well I like honestly most of
idiots Lantern like that story is trying
to be taken seriously and it's stupid oh
good Gwendoline I feel like we've done
this dance before this I'm getting deja
vu here
so either you and I have done have done
this already or you are doing what
somebody else did a few weeks back and I
can't be entirely certain which is the
case but the way you will just worded it
that last time literally asking me what
my private parts are
none of your damn business
like absolutely none of your business
and I we've gone through this before
because I remember last time it was it
was all caps questions too so at this
point if we cycle through this again I'm
just gonna assume you're trolling and
I'll block you and I don't mean that as
a threat I mean that as like you're
literally repeating the same rude
question over and over and over again I
don't know what else to do with you so
I'm not trying to be a jerk but come on
now look if you have trouble reconciling
what you're seeing it is not my job to
align you okay if if the if the
incongruity of what you were seeing
makes you uncomfortable and you can't
proceed without answers that I'm not
going to give you - not the way your
wording these questions this is not my
problem this is your baggage to figure
out how you're gonna handle we're gonna
leave it at that because this is eaten
up a bit more of the chat than it should
of those because I know we we've been
through this before uh thanks for your
video essay on the series now I am an
avid Red Dwarf fan whoo love it favorite
characters rumors facial expressions or
alone are the best Rimmer is amazing
like he really he really doesn't make
that show beak and what I love about
Rimmer especially um oh okay you know
what that has now crossed over into
they're just looking for reasons to be
abusive so there we go
okay we took care of that anyway back to
Red Dwarf what is terrific about
Rimmer's that Rimmer's
character that on paper should be
grading it's something I've said
repeatedly is so hard it is such a hard
needle to thread which is a character
that is annoying to the characters we
like because we like Lister Lister's a
lovable guy and when you have Rimmer who
irritates the ever-loving heck out of
not only Lister but everybody it's
really hard to have a character who
irritates the other characters but
doesn't also irritate the audience and
Rimmer pulls that off he's like the
golden example of how to do it right and
there is no better way to illustrate
that the American version that never got
past the pilot and the American Rimmer
is terrible because he's lacking in the
little touches that make original Rimmer
work and make you like to have him
around as opposed to wish you would go
away would you let ended up happening in
the American average American version
I'm pretty I'm pretty sure the pilot for
the American version is still like
freely uploaded on YouTube it was a few
years ago it's been a while since I've
looked if you haven't seen it you need
to because again like especially anybody
who's interested in writing or video
production or narrative or just comedy
because it Cribbs so much of the
original yet does not work it's a great
comparison to just realize how little
tiny twists to the way something is
executed will make it work or not it's
it's really great yes it's online
awesome there were two tries at the
remake so far it can seem um so when
they tried to do the American version of
Red Dwarf
there's the pilot that's like actually
online that you can see that was their
first pass at the pilot they had another
go at it with a different cat which was
weird because the cat they had was fine
and a different Rimmer I don't think you
can actually find that we run it about
an hour so it will be
it'll be ten o'clock my time the Eastern
Standard so when we hit the next hour
that's that's what that's when I'm gonna
end UK office UK or us neither I don't
really care for the office if you're
gonna make me pick I'll take the u.s.
because I really he really don't like
Ricky Gervais like I gotta at a visceral
level I just know he just me it makes me
angry like just his face yeah I can't I
can't
buffer and lay yeah I'm gonna blame the
weather like I said it's it's actually
thunder lightning where I am depends on
wasn't the water runs out that's okay
bear with me folks
doo-doo-doo-doo let's see and boom there
we go
I don't like to people really have
nothing better to do than harass a live
stream people get their kicks from odd
stuff sometimes like I did I've never
gotten the appeal I just I just don't
just wondering would you ever consider
doing videos ranking the dalek or
Cybermen designs or stories yeah yeah I
mean that ranking a new series at low
modern era Dalek stories and Cybermen
stories that both of those are on the
docket well I'll get to them I am
absolutely no clue but they're on the
to-do list
Oh with a thousand other things since
you like Love Actually have you ever
seen The Vicar of Dibley
I have not I'm aware of it I like I've
heard the name but I never did see it
thoughts on the show galavant
I love galavant galavant is also on the
to-do list to do why it's awesome like I
I have a decal on the back of my I was
gonna say new month old now car that is
a lizard lizard then that says
underneath it I super believe and if
you've seen galavant you know what I'm
saying about what I'm saying and what
that means and and everything else but
like season 1 of galavant is fun season
two weeks
awesome yeah I love that show I love
this just so much and I'm so glad I got
a second season doctor like end properly
dad that was a huge relief your sticker
is amazing where did you find it
let's see good times tad Cooper yep
that's him
we named one of our Turtles galavant and
won Missy no Magdalena did you ever like
Gallagher I've never really seen any of
Gallagher's stuff I think largely
because what I know of his comedy is
like if you're not at a live show I'm
not entirely sure it's gonna work well
forgive the pun have the same impact
favorite band of all time oh oh I don't
know maybe Queen but like I'm gonna have
a different answer depending on when you
ask me that
not sure about Galvin nor heard of it to
be honest well it's on Netflix it's two
seasons relatively short seasons
half-hour episodes it is a medieval set
musical comedy and like that's the best
way to describe it you know with
ridiculous characters that get even more
ridiculous in the second season
yeah aside I just adore it what is the
worst pun you've ever heard I don't know
probably expunged it from my brain or
it's one that I myself have said and
probably by exit you know what I've
actually noticed a lot and it seemed to
be have any more frequent leaves I'll
get comments on my video
people like quoting something I said
over the course of review or you know a
video or whatever and they'll go hey was
this a pun and I'll look at and go I
guess it was not on purpose it wasn't
like he was a nice rule of thumb if I do
a pun and realize that I did
it I'll make a dumb face be like just
because I can't believe I said something
like that but if I make what sounds like
a pun and I don't do that I didn't
realize that I did it and that happens
rather frequently crazy ex-girlfriend is
better than gallivant crazy
ex-girlfriend is honestly despite also
be a musical comedy a very different
beast from galavant
they are they're parroting completely
different genres and tropes so I find
the comparison a bit odd like you'd
think it'd be an actual composition
comparison to both musical comedies you
know why wouldn't you compare them but
there's settings characters tone the
source that types of source material the
jokes are meant to send up it's a
completely different ballgame
do you like the Discworld series I've
still only read the one so far the
monstrous regimen um but I did like it
quite a bit so one of these days and I
have time maybe I'll read more that's
that's a dream how do you wake up Lady
gaga oh god is this a setup to a joke
that I'm gonna groan at um poker face
anyone no oh God uh how's your vacation
my vacation was lovely I mentioned
earlier you already have a book on your
plate yes Caroline I know which I am I
am actually it's I'm not like two days
in a row making progress on it I'm
building a habit out of it I will get
through it yet my vacation was good I
mentioned earlier it was a family
vacation and it was actually probably
the best one we've taken in a lot of
ways we get well partially goes the last
two years somebody got sick the the
previous two years but this
not only did nobody get sick but my
daughter is at that age my daughter's
seven now where she is just old enough
to that we can entrust her and she also
wants to do some stuff on her own and
she doesn't need us there for everything
but she's also not yet at the point
where she's like shooing us away and
doesn't want us around so it gives me in
her mother a bit of a break and a
breather a chance to go to the bar right
now and then and not feel like we're
abandoning her because she's she's fine
and she's very self sufficient for a
seven-year-old liquor I hardly knew her
whereabouts
Iren aii that i am gonna consider like
you know personal information that the
types of details of like exactly where
we do find litigation because we do it
every year and like i don't that that
seems and also because i it's
information about more than just me it
was just my vacation that'd be one thing
but like it involves my daughter and her
mother i'm like that's that's
information that i do try and limit the
specifics on just out of out of privacy
concerns like especially when i start
dealing with other people like my own
privacy i like what i have of it but you
know that guy I put I'm putting myself
out there I try to be very careful about
not putting other people out there
especially if they don't know that I'm
doing it do you think doctor who could
or should ever do an episode on
Stonewall and if so how do you think
they should approach it given my
incredibly mixed feelings about Rosa I
would kind of rather they didn't do you
think Russell T Davies should return for
an episode as it's been long enough
since he left and his style of writing
perfectly suits the current artists team
and era
I'm gonna give an answer and I don't
like the reason I'm gonna give this
answer no but not because he couldn't
write a good story or it wouldn't be a
good fit for this team but because with
things as volatile as they are right now
all that would result is a flood of
people screaming at him to come back and
run the show and like even if the
Chibnall
era as we are currently in the middle of
was not as divisive as it is so far
approving to be that is still something
that would probably happen but if if we
were dealing with a less divisive era of
Doctor Who I wouldn't be as deafening as
I expect it would be if that actually
happened and I don't have the stomach to
deal with it and that's a stupid reason
um cuz like form up from a purely could
he write for this team oh yeah he told
what they could I bet he could do great
with them even but like it just is what
it is I think you're right about our DT
I think if he'd done it during Moffat
singer or would have been fine but not
now yeah that's kind of where I am have
you seen the boys answer that earlier
know if I've opted to skip it cuz I'm
not a fan of Garth Ennis who are the
original comics um come on you can say
you went to the Bates Motel there's
always a vacancies those a vacancy yeah
six rooms six vacancies I know if it was
six been too long stuff seen psycho
that's a good movie though what's your
favorite mixed drink I don't know if I
have a favorite like my go-to if I'm if
nothing else catches my eye is a whiskey
sour
cuz it's nice and easy any bartender
knows how to make it so like that's my
default I'm not sure it's my favorite
though it's gin it's just like my safety
net drink why do they remake villains
hot ie Jafar and Hordak I'm not sure I
even have a problem with that
would we go or duck hot though well
you've seen this latest season minor
spoilers I guess first season three of
Shira he's he's pretty amazing when we
get a better look at him would we call
that hot I mean like a big I guess cuz
they gave indiscernible hair which he
didn't used to have I don't know I feel
like that was a stretch
sexy Jafar was odd to me now that's
based off trails I haven't actually seen
the movie and I won't but yeah I don't
know I think it's one of those things
that it becomes well we just have to
find a way to do it different than last
time and because before these these
villains weren't sexy that just becomes
kind of by default what they end up
becoming he does have a gentlemen's
haircut oh yes
leading the whole but crushing the
rebellion you watch boss I don't know
why that's that came out as it did or
why I'm sticking with it also philosophy
to for master casting Oh that'd be
interesting I I like I kind of want to
see him like do I don't know like like
give him a monologue from the war master
or something from from Jacoby's stud see
what he does with it at the very least
I'd love to see that with James Mason as
god yes always were you dragged to the
Lion King yeah yeah my daughter really
wanted to see it Hordak has that emo bod
all the young folk like I guess I don't
know what young folk like I have no clue
Vader was hot on Mustafar
[Laughter]
do you like the bad guy turn good trope
is it a trope it is a trope in
long-running fiction because basically
and
thing that runs for a long time be it a
TV show or a comic book or even some
film series if they run long enough if
you have a villain that is a fan
favorite character it's almost
inevitable if you never kill them off
that they will in some way either turn
good or become some kind of antihero
because you want to be able to keep
bringing them back but if you keep
bringing back the same villain and have
them defeated over and over and over and
over again they no longer work as a
villain because they lose every time
so the way you keep characters like that
around is to turn them into some kind of
good guy that's what happens with
characters like spike on Buffy the
Vampire Slayer is a very good example so
yeah it's definitely a trope in
long-running fiction specifically what
do I feel about it
it's a case by case scenario I do feel
at this point it is pretty predictable
it happens a lot but it can be done well
it's it's one of those tropes that is
malleable enough that it can be made to
work it's not like oh god this again
it's it's all good Wow any tropes
execution dependent but that one like in
a way that like you can still pull this
off there are ways to do it but spike is
great but honestly I find it more fun as
a bad guy
I don't know I I agree with that so hold
on I gotta jump back to the discord real
quick the discord somebody just put up
that that video of Jonathan Frakes
interrogate cyou I'm not answering all
those okay so he pulled one question
from those can up hair really give a
girl the will to live sure there is
beauty in all things and whatever gives
you joy and hope and the will to live
that is valid and if it's a parent sure
I buy it are you looking forward to your
Harry Potter rewatch I guess that's a
that's a bomb for anybody who's not on
the patreon and therefore knows the
docket this month I'm gonna be star
a rewatch of all the so far released
Harry Potter movies starting with
Philosopher's Stone was gonna be source
for a stone for me because I I'm in the
US but and going all the way through
crimes are green to hold uh in release
order um I am looking forward to it I
knowing some of the nitpicks I already
have about some of those movies I'm I'm
weary of what I'm gonna get back in the
feedback but but I I am I actually
haven't rewatched most of those in a
long time um so yeah I am looking
forward to that see can't wait for those
videos oh good
is Batman overrated no because Batman is
malleable enough with enough variations
that you can get a specific flavor of
Batman and when you say Batman is
honestly anything it's like well which
version of Batman are you talking about
is Batman overused by Warner Brothers
because they feel like they have to have
50 versions of Batman and cancel a bunch
of other unique books you know with
their comics lines with DC and Marvel
and ever and I'm sorry Marvel DC or
Warner Brothers and everything else yes
they do too much with with Batman is he
overrated no some iterations of him are
overrated not all of them some are
underappreciated let's remake Citizen
Kane with more explosions oh yeah yeah
seriously why did that sled not blow up
when it was in the fire I get get
Michael Bay to remake Citizen Kane I
actually legitimately want to see that
now have you watched Young Justice new
yeah that's another one of the ones that
I've heard great things but I never have
how would you fix fear her um throw away
the script and write something else like
there's honestly there's really nothing
and fear her that works at all I can't
even really be certain what they were
going for with that one like I could
look at something like love and monsters
and I can see everything that went wrong
but I can also see the initial kernel of
an idea that could have been good I got
nothing on fear her I look at that I'm
like you just don't scrap the whole
thing there's nothing to build anything
out of with that Harry Potter revisit I
grew up on the movies yeah yeah good
times
Citizen Kane made entirely with sock
puppets must be a reality go forth and
make that rosebud boom yep yeah that
sounds right I mean that that's how you
leave the theatre right we are gonna
wrap up soon folks as I said I do need
to actually a hard stop at ten cuz I've
got I've got videos to shoot popping
back to the discord real quick um
favorite rock band favorite pop artist
favorite popcorn just kidding
favorite popcorn actually the popcorn
from my local movie theater because they
use real cabinet butter so there's that
uh favorite rock band somebody asked
that already in the in the chat I mean I
think I'll go with Queen but like there
aren't there aren't a ton that I'm like
yeah all in on the like for everything
they've done there's bloody that I like
but I'm not like I'm not massively
devoted really to to many musical acts
at all that said favorite pop artist
pink like that that one's easy
and I'll I'll bang out the last few of
these from the discord what's your
favorite season fall all but your
favorite Doctor Who episode
of all the episodes you've seen so far
probably city of death that's that's
really tough though favorite 80s cartoon
Real Ghostbusters it's one of the only
ones that holds up Robert Pattinson his
Batman could work I mean they got the
guy's resume right now is not vastly
dissimilar from what Christian Bale's
was before he took on Batman so yeah I
mean I'll I want to see what he what he
can do
did you miss the picture I think you
might get a kick out of it no I did see
a game that you he put stuff in the
discord um I I didn't mention it here
because like that's obviously a visual
that I can't share right here so like I
skipped it but I didn't I did see it I
did read it I did get a kick out of it
so thanks for that doctor who is for
squares oh dang call me you Luis cuz
it's hip to be square I wish I could
have thought of something better than
that
but that's all I got you're genuinely
one of my biggest heroes who inspire me
every day thank you for being who you
are it helps a lot of people oh dang Wow
okay thank you
that's whoa thanks a lot of ji I really
appreciate that Batman but he's a
Scotsman if you're asking for me to do
that no I think that's just good that
would just be an embarrassment to to
everyone involved if you could save
three Doctor Who stories from being
wiped what would you pick do it I did a
list of a hundred don't ask me for three
come on I'm jealous of your glasses so
there oh I I love these guys they took a
little while to grow me but I do
really
don't Batman but he's a Scotsman who
reminds me of Monty Python's yes I know
God people people are like phonetically
typing out Batman dialogue in a Scottish
accent oh oh dear I like how American
Psycho said it best hey Paul yeah that's
how American Psycho did it the internet
is for being embarrassed well then I I
am I'm a frequenter of that going back
and seeing some of my stuff sometimes
but I I think I am gonna I'm gonna wrap
it up there get your I know it's good
now so that's the thing like I actually
I can or at least I think I can do like
a reasonable horrible American
approximation of Scottish but I feel
like now have like I've too much in my
head with it and it would be more
embarrassing than then it then it
automatically would already be but yeah
we're uh we're gonna wrap it up so folks
so thank you so much for joining me I
hope you had a good last week hope you
have a good rest of this week I'll see
you Tuesday next week which will be post
terrific on which I yeah this weekend at
Mohegan Sun in Connecticut with Liz in
cosplay at least two of those days so
that'll be fun and the next week's live
stream will probably just be me relaying
most of that cuz I might shoot some
stuff there I don't know if it'll
actually be anything I use cuz I don't
like have a plan but yeah that'll
that'll wrap it up for now so thank you
for joining me counsel
I'm just running meetings and
occasionally stopping myself from doing
horrible Scottish accents on live
streams so have a good night